now i felt the pressure to get a big
guest on first up for this season
and i think that i've got him he's led
bulla to a heartland championship
he's played in russia he's become a
tasman hero
he was a hurricane star he won super
rugby with a drop goal for the landers
he then went off to italy with traviso
came back to the landers now he's making
millions of yen
in japan it is the great man himself
marty banks welcome banksy thanks for
coming on jabba
i've avoided you for about a year um i
didn't think i'd have enough on the show
because there's uh probably two people
i would not trust on a phone call and
one's yourself and one's joe wheeler
and uh i never thought i'd ever sit on a
podcast with you but here i am that
hey thanks for coming on giving up your
time i know you're
flat out at the moment over in japan
yeah flat out watching prison break but
uh
got a day off mate so i'll make time for
you yeah how much prison break have you
watched
uh your brother got me to it um
regretfully
um in the last week i think i banged out
the whole the whole series so
um yeah four four seasons i think it was
i
took toad through the first season and
then now it got me hooked one and sinker
for the last
four so um happy to see the back end of
the end of it
that's what like 40 hours worth of no
we worked it out it was 60 something
hours and uh yeah
it's not in the last week and a half
it's uh
it's i don't know whether that's an
achievement or if it's uh stupidity but
uh like i said i'm finished it today and
i'm glad it's gone because
i might get some sort of life back what
sort of training are you guys not
training at the moment what's the
situation in japan
um now we're training um i normally pick
my pick my uh four hours up after
training six till ten
get in bed i'll just live a night life
on uh
on pretty much auto auto auto repeat
just day after day but
um now we're training so monday tuesday
and then thursday friday jabba so uh
yeah just chipping away long days though
leave it
leave the door at 6 30 and get home at
six so
tough at the cold face mate so what
about the cooking and stuff how are you
feeling time to cook
um probably don't really cook too much
well because on the
on our training days we get given dinner
um so
before we head home we get a dinner it's
not massive i don't eat all of it
because uh
most of it's fish so i try and avoid
that but uh get home
park up chuck and ubereats call in and
they drop off a wee
a wee snack and uh i'm not like you mate
i don't have a mrs over here or
toei toei comes home and it's all
prepared so
i slave way on a wednesday i'll cook on
my days off but uh not too much during
the week
[ __ ] i thought by now you would have
been able to cook yourself a meal
i can cook myself a meal jabber it's not
anything spectacular but uh
yeah i can hold my own so you must be
missing the girlfriend then
yeah i guess it's uh pretty tough work
doing your own cleaning and your own
washing but uh no it's
it is actually you come home and like i
said that's where the old
prison break probably fills in my time
because you come home and it's sort of
home to an empty house and um so that
sort of it gets a bit tough
um spent a bit of time in tojo's back
pocket there with him and beth playing
the second child so
they take me out get me out of the house
a little bit here and there
and then what's the go with the japanese
comp over there it seems like a pretty
weird situation
yeah we're not really too sure um i've
postponed the first three weeks
uh yeah like we've been doing pretty
uh sorry pretty well with uh coronavirus
i think we've only had a couple of small
cases but uh
some of the top teams have been hit so i
think
whether it's been delayed completely
because of that
would probably be my guess i think kobe
had a bit of
a covert there and suntory um
a couple of other teams as well so when
teams like that are probably
the main the main teams in the comp here
i guess uh
the powers that will would probably want
them guys playing so
the little teams like us that are
covered free get punished because uh
the other teams aren't doing so well for
it but the plan is to start on the sixth
um sixth of february not too sure who we
play we either play hino who's our first
game
or maybe kobe i think who is scheduled
to be our third so
waiting for that to work itself out are
we gonna see the tj
banks martial combo yeah i don't know
it's uh it's been interesting the first
uh the last bit of pre-season anyway
when tj gets here so well since tj's
been here it's been uh
towie in the 15 jersey and tj at nine
and um
the rest of the boys are japanese
qualified or asian passport holders in
the back line so
um whether we'll see tj and me and tom
i'm not sure i hope so
at some stage but uh at the moment it's
predominantly south african fords and
and uh towie and tj so that's the way it
is though but um
it's just awesome to see the team going
going forward this year uh last year was
a bit of a
tough season copying 97 points in
anyone's
book isn't great so to see us competing
at the moment in pre-season obviously
waters have been untested because the
season hasn't started yet but uh
at the moment we're looking pretty good
that's good eh and
you must be one of the highest paid
non-23 players in the world if you're
not in the 23
hey oh i'd say uh i'm probably not i'm
sure uh
i'm sure you're probably the most high
fade coach out there if i've ever seen
one but uh
no i don't mind running the water um it
hurts my feelings though
getting out there and not being a part
of it but gonna take it on the chin mate
it's all part and parcel i think
uh the way the rules are you can only
play uh five
foreigners i think we might get six um
because we'll go to fiji and boy
in the national sevens team so um the
rules mean when to
when jojo's away we get another
foreigner and so
um so hopefully i can squeeze into the
six at some stage and
get a few minutes under the belt you
also have pretty stacked um team or
foreigners they even
mumpimpi the south african winger he
can't even crack the
starting lineup at the moment too so
there's some pretty
good talent not playing for your side
yeah the pimps has been awesome though
he's uh
he's come over full of energies he's a
top man
and the japanese boys love him i think
what our team lacked probably last year
in the last few years is just
we haven't been able to have the
foreigners input to help
coach the group so it's predominantly
been only a couple of us but now we've
got
i can't even i'd start a number out
there probably eight or nine
ten foreigners here at the moment um and
guys like tj and they're offering their
sort of
expertise and tojo helping the back
three like you can just see the
the intellectual growth of the team like
growing uh week on week and
in the four pack i don't know much about
ford's but i'm sure the the south
african boys are doing the same for
for that side of it so yeah i think that
that's probably where we lacked
is just we didn't have that reach
because we've got a squad of 50 so for
having
three coaches it's pretty tough for them
to coach individually so
to have the boys now it's sort of
happening naturally which is good and
like i said i think that'll help us when
we do transition into the season if
it does kick off and how do the japanese
boys find you do they
do they understand your banter your
japanese um
the japanese they don't really get the
sarcasm um we've been trying to
bait a few of them up and they don't
take it very well so we're gonna be
pretty careful um we've got a couple of
boys that
are sort of coming to grips with the
fact that we're not that serious
um your brother in particular um but now
they're all good boys like you wouldn't
meet a bitter a bit a bunch of boys for
sure they're
an awesome culture and um you know that
they welcomed us in will welcome me in
for when i first got here and uh
they haven't kicked me out yet um but
you'll see how that goes at the end of
the season
[Laughter]
good stuff but anyway we've got lots to
get through so
um let's go back to the start for young
martin banks let's take us back to
reefton what was it like for you
yeah it was good i actually tried
venturing up to nelson when i was uh i
think i was 12 or 13.
um yeah i realized that you lived there
the superstar of nelson college so i
thought
i'll try and stick to my my small pond
of reefton um
but no it's uh yeah i think richton
probably had it's good things and it's
bad things um
growing up i guess you grew up in a
small town and i don't know he ended up
playing sports and i don't know it's
pretty easy to be the best when there's
not many sport people around and
um i think growing up in that sort of
life so i think i got pretty hard
hit when uh when i came to the real
world and meant to
come and meet some of the big boys of
the rugby world but
um but yeah as a lifestyle it was
awesome love to get back there don't
know if we ever lived there again
but always just like getting back there
for the race day and bumped into you a
couple of times there and
yeah it was uh it was good times so you
were one of six am i right and saying
that
one of six yeah uh four boys two four
boys two girls so
um i think i was a bit of an
afterthought and there's a massive gap
between me and the next oldest
uh probably call myself a mistake there
jabba but
i'm sure mum still loves me
and then how did you get into rugby or
did you you obviously you're pretty
talented from a very young age the star
of reefed in from five
star reaching for five da i think um i
started when i was
uh the old man had rugby post built when
i was about three or four
they're only about a meter high a meter
wide um he used to run over top of me
that probably
flowed into my later life where people
run over top of me jabba but uh
um but it started yeah nothing that's
dad hadn't done that to me when i was
three years old i probably would have
been right now but
yeah you know i'm still on facebook it
cuts me deep down but i just don't show
it
but uh it just started i was just like
any other
um boy really boy or girl as a as you
grow up you follow your parents and
the other family members around their
sporting fields and um
yeah and i was just one of those guys
that would jump in the truck and go to
the rugby game on saturday and then
sunday morning i'd be off to watch rugby
league and um
like i said i probably ended up in a pub
too early um
reason really had no rules so as long as
you're sitting beside your old man or
your brother
you could uh pretty much do what you
wanted so in that respect
probably wasn't good for good for the
old upbringing but um
yeah it's just the way it goes in small
small towns mate
i used to sneak the old beer yeah used
to get give it
god now this is this is later on this is
probably a 10 or 11. um
sneaking drinks sneaking drinks off the
old man um
yeah but it's pretty much my whole life
from i'd say three to
not four no not drinking at three but
like following you run around the rugby
fields from three till
probably till i was 16 and i was planned
rugby alongside the old man so
yeah so 13 years of
following sport and drinking beer mate
and you ended up playing with your old
man
hey yeah um yeah i don't know what he's
up to there he's like 55 probably even
older
i don't actually think he knew how old
he was to be fair um
but yeah so there was all of us uh
brothers we played the old game
throughout the time and
during i think it was 2005 and 6.
um the old man he didn't play many
minutes he came off the bench for about
10
got red carded and uh yeah like i think
they're
hung the boots up after that um yeah so
it's uh didn't get to play the final
with him but it's pretty special though
it's something that
i'll probably never get to do with my
son because i've probably left that run
a bit late but
um i think if anyone ever got the chance
i think
it meant the world to me um you know
watching dad play for so many years and
then
getting to play alongside him um yeah
not not many
you know sons get to do that so that was
pretty lucky
what do you get the red card for missing
he threw an air punch and then got
then got dropped so um so he got hurt
and
yeah so he missed and got a black eye
but
it was pretty cool though we got to go
through the final and
end up having a beer i think i was maybe
15 then having a
legal beer on the coast um but yeah it
was a good bus trip home so
got to have a beer alongside him even
though he couldn't play what position
were you playing at 15
10 and hiding senior rugby
senior rugby yeah i had um my brother
was playing 12.
um yeah yeah so yeah
like let's be honest jimmy the the rugby
i think you even said it yourself i
think you
uh got down to bulla one week and told
the buller coach that if
you had a ford pack you'd win the comp
um
so the competition was never real real
strong but
um it's like any senior footy though
like you go out the country and
just big men that just they won't get
you many times when they get you they'll
make sure you know about it so i just
tried not to be hit too many times
obviously didn't go into contact too
many times and uh we're not winning too
many tackles either so
i came out unscathed mate fair enough
but then you ended up
playing for bulla guiding them to the
heartland championship
talk me through that yeah i think the
bullet thing came about because uh
and i think it was 2006 um i was
actually going to play that year but my
old lady wouldn't let me because she
realizes a little bit of a step up from
club rugby to playing heartland or
mpc division two or whatever it was back
then or is that long ago but uh
so i was actually gonna do it then and
then the old lady knocked it on the head
um
and it was it was largely just because
um the old man he played
a hundred games for buller and um i
guess it becomes sort of part of who you
are growing up in the region it's sort
of
getting the opportunity to go back and
play for bulla um just on the off chance
i got injured
um playing in christchurch it sort of
just fell into place but
it was awesome like i knew a lot of the
boys growing up and they were in the
team as well and um
and then obviously when i played senior
european 2005 and six i'd actually
played a lot
a lot against a lot of the boys that
were in the team so they were probably
40 by then but um but yeah so
it was an awesome awesome comp it's uh
you know
something i look back on pretty fondly
and if i ever got the chance again i'd
probably like to pull on the ball of
jersey again
um probably just to give just to give
back a little bit because uh
without buller i wouldn't have met um
ben komen and uh james foster
and that way there was a waimea boy and
a nelson
uh football club player there and um
they were the ones actually convinced me
to go up to nelson to
have a crack at tasman and um nearly
ended up at your club
um i don't think you would have been
there but um being coman twisted my arm
and
and shacked me up at his so i think you
know the little things like that you
sort of at the time you're not really
too aware of but looking back like
that sort of moment probably shaped the
rest of my career
so then you did make that move up to
nelson had a
standout season for weimer old boys
uh but you missed out on uh the tasman
marker so talk me through that took me
through that decision in that year
yeah i think it's uh i don't know i was
just i was pretty
had a crack in canterbury um i found out
there's a massive production line there
and
obviously went back to bulla and um
looking at tazzy and they're like i had
a few mates that moved up
um kieran fonatiere and um i'd sort of
bumped into shane christie a little bit
um through the canterbury uh crusaders
development and stuff like that so
and they sort of planted a seed um i
wasn't too really
wasn't really aware of where i'd sit in
the scheme of things once i moved up
there but
um decided to move up and end up at
waimea like i said through
being coman and he took me under his
wing there i lived with him and
him and his partner in the house there
and
um yeah it was like living with you
again well actually before i live with
you
uh i was a little i was a little boy
again um
but yeah nelson was awesome i went up
there and like you say i missed that on
the team
uh and i think you know i met kk
kk and leon and i still remember sitting
in the office
when they came to naming the team and i
thought that i'd probably done enough to
sneak in the back door and pick up one
of the last spots and
i remember kk set me down and i've
talked about it in the past but i've
never really acknowledged
that kk was probably right he said i
wasn't ready and
looking back now i probably wasn't ready
he said like
if i was under under his and leon's
tutelage for a couple of years then i
would be
and uh and at the time i was i was
pretty pissed off i was
i was gutted that i hadn't sort of made
the initial squad and
um then when i did get my chance and
then obviously made the tasman team and
things went the way they did and
it wasn't till later that i realized
keiko was actually right until i
until i went up and met you at the canes
and had that year and
um that's where i think i realized that
kk was actually talking about
further down the line because he said in
two years it had me playing super rugby
and
you know when you're a little kid or not
a little kid a younger guy you're like
all i want to do is now play now and do
this but
i think he was thinking long term but i
was pretty short-sighted so
um i wish i had kk there to give me the
word of advice saying you probably need
another year before you get a super
rugby but
i was pretty naive and went on my own a
little way and
found out the hard way but that's the
way it goes so how did you get that
crack
um for tasman because you you said you
weren't ready but then you
you played for tasman it must have been
three or four rounds into the comp
with the 4xl t-shirt and yes
i don't know if it was four xl i think i
was there was another thing like i
probably wasn't physically ready
i wasn't physically ready i think it was
probably a medium but i still remember
seeing some photos mate it was uh
i've seen that jersey i've never seen it
after the season but it was huge you
know
it was probably a combination of me
being so skinny probably about 80 kg and
the jersey being too big but
um yeah it's sort of like looking back
that tasman team was
stacked and um for some reason the boys
struggled
um in the first couple of games i think
the first family
was against tasman uh not tasman against
southland sorry we're obviously tasman
but we struggled down there and then the
second round i can't remember who that
was
but then robbie picked up an injury um
before counties and
um i remember i was working for a
builder
andrew martin uh he sort of pulled me
aside
as he's a associate of the warmer club
and he's let me do a bit of cash work
for him
um probably making his lunch more than
anything on the building site but uh so
at the time i was working for him and i
remember tasman
i can't remember who called me but they
were trying to get me to come in and
train like
with the team like during the week and
take time off work
and i still remember saying something
like look like i can't just come in and
give two days a week
because obviously i wanna live and i
gotta have you know money coming in so i
was like
when you call me and say you can pay me
for my time that i come in on
during the week like after five o'clock
or six o'clock it's fine but
going in from nine till five unpaid was
sort of
sort of bit out of reach so a couple of
weeks after i got a phone call
and they said i will pay you to come in
for this week and it was again before
the county's game i didn't think i was
going to play off but it was just me
going to learn
and i remember kk came up to me and he
was like oh
and we're going to play you this week i
was like oh fire out like there's one
team that you probably don't want to
debut against and that's
probably counties because back then they
had some big boys like
and remember i was 80 kg and pasty white
and i just remember looking at that team
and
like they had frank harlow and he was
going ballistic shoe and stairs
there's some big fours and i was just
like i'm not ready for this like
give me another week let me let me go
back and play southland or something
like it's uh let the white battler play
the white battles but um
yeah kk threw me in the mix of the earth
leon and i still remember them asking
what position i i feel comfortable at
and
at the time like i went to school and
and christchurch boys and
up until christchurch boys i played 10
and then got to christchurch boys i met
tyler blindo and
he was sort of the golden boy i think he
was at the same time as you probably
went toe-to-toe quite a bit
um so when i got there tyler was
obviously the 10 so i sort of just
floated around
any of the other positions where i could
pick up time and i always thought i was
at 10 until i got to christchurch and
then from there i started playing
fullback
and that's where i thought i was going
to end up so
just when kk asked me i was like oh i
think i'm a better fallback than 10.
and anyway that's where he put me and i
still remember during that game it went
there's good patches and average
pictures but i remember in the second
half
like it was julie and we had a midfield
scrum it was a 4-2 split
and i was trying to call the ball off me
because i just dropped a ball but i
literally dropped it cold
and i went up to your brother and i was
like just go left and like
just let me just let me recover here and
uh
it came right it came right and i
dropped it again um it went backwards
thankfully but like those
those two moments i looked back and i
was like far out like i was just a deer
in the headlights like i was just like
far out like am i
am i good enough to be here and i think
i was just lucky like i said the team
was so good
that when i did go on to the second for
not second five minutes of first five
the team pretty much functioned on its
own and i think that's the team hit its
straps probably the week after that we
played otago
and uh run them off the park and from
that point like the team just
it was just automatic like i just didn't
have to do much i was probably lucky
that
i've been put into 10 then because like
i said it just run itself we had
players in the back line like your
brother and that did most of the work
and uh i just threw on the ball pretty
much and obviously it
looked like i was done a lot but i
probably wasn't doing a heck of a lot to
be
i fair so humble and you obviously
became one of the
tasman heroes um started your own
facebook page the legend of marty banks
which has over
100 000 followers
i think that's actually more famous than
anything i achieved mate
it's uh got nothing to do with me but
he's done a hell of a lot better than i
have
you get asked that a lot i know a few
people ask that question uh why did you
set up that facebook page
and call it the legend of marty banks
now you normally get some older people
that don't really understand and
they ask me why i'm posting this stuff
and why i'm talking about this stuff and
like it's it's not me like so
i'm sure there's a lot of people out
there that think it's the stupid
person being me posting this stuff and
like i remember back
early on like i remember there was a few
i could always take the digs at me like
i was fine with that but
i remember there's a few times where a
couple of posts would get put up about
teammates or
opposition and stuff like that and i'm
like i'll just if you're going to come
on anyone as a joke just come at me
because like i don't really want this
tied to
tied to me so i was a bit worried about
it at that start but i messaged and he
ever since then he's been pretty good
and um he's doing what he's doing and
obviously it's sort of branched out to a
bit more than just about marty banks
which is ideal
is it true you're paying him i wish i
had that sort of money to pay him
but now he's uh he actually went to
wreston and uh i think he actually did a
photo shoot
at the reefs and races for my sister i
think they were doing a
fashion in the fields thing so he's met
the family
yeah i don't know too much other more
than that though
oh good and obviously your um
championship
final was a big moment of your tasman
career
the big memory that stands out for
everyone you're getting your
intercept try hot dogging pointing up to
god
and about the halfway knowing that
you've got the guests
what a g wizard yeah because i think
that all came from
ah because that whole year was always
because
obviously the premiership and the
championship but it was always the thing
about
me and ehire and ehr and me and um i
remember that whole week was just there
was just people into me about how ehi
was gonna
tear us the bits and all this sort of
stuff and i just remembered like i never
ever got worked up before a game
and uh for some reason when i got that
interceptor i
i look back on it and i've apologized to
so many people for it
i should not celebrate ever and i should
not celebrate before half time
because like it's just not smart i i
think
just their emotions just took over and
um yeah
i actually didn't even know if i was on
side so i shouldn't have been
celebrating because i wasn't actually
sure if i was safe so i remember
scoring and your brother was there i was
like was i even on side he was like i
don't know and then
i just sort of came about that i was
just by chance so
yeah i can't really remember too much i
remember uh
in that second half i had a brain
explosion and kicked the crossfield kick
they end up in a try and
i remember just thinking in my head i
was like fired up just cost us a game
keiko is going to have me by the nuts
here and i remember walking off after
the game would we'd still won
and i couldn't look cake on the eye
because i was so terrified that he was
going to come at me about it so i
literally probably avoided him for
i would say the whole whole interview do
i would say i didn't want anything to do
with it
[Laughter]
and then obviously the other final that
you played in was the premiership final
one yeah i knew this was i knew this was
going to come up i knew this was coming
up i remember you and actually
that whole year i actually talked about
this the other day and we played you
boys
obviously early on in the season
obviously down in
and down and nelson there and the one
who's come back and won late in the
peace
and uh 82 minutes yeah
and it was uh i still remember i think
it was i'm pretty sure it was this game
it could be i could have crossed across
my wires here but i remember there was
you and kurt baker
and uh i think marty mckenzie run a one
three cup of sita tamanevalu
and uh this game i remember it was it
the same game yeah
yeah and uh sits obviously went through
me and scored
um and literally
it happened that fast that somehow kurt
had come from wherever he came from
you would come from wherever you would
come from and you were both just
in my grill i would say i don't know it
felt like an eternity but you
were just in my grill the whole and it
like ever since then i was just like i
hadn't actually met kurt before then
and i went on to meet i actually went on
to play at the highlanders with kurt but
until the point where i actually met him
i thought he was a complete
[ __ ] and i actually had much to do
with you either and
other than tom being your brother i
actually thought you were an [ __ ]
too so
um yeah so like it was uh
i still haven't let that brush off my
back but then obviously
i think it got us a tree in the end oh
we ended up
yeah that hurt that's uh yeah i still
don't know how we lost that game it
wasn't it wasn't great but that's the
way it goes jebber and you take that on
in your stride but yeah then the final
just happened again i didn't get
steamrolled in the final but the whole
game i could just
you and kurt were just chipping away and
uh
like it was just relentless like it
didn't it wasn't anything that hurt me
like mentally or anything but it was
just like the annoyance of your voice
just
like talking absolute crap like it's a
painful voice to listen to and then
you've got both of you is just going
left and right it's just like
far out so if you were coughing two
voices i was coughing about 10. that
whole marco
team was into me that day that was
ruthless yeah
you probably deserved it it's probably
been probably all that time you spent at
the marcos
those boys just probably bottled it all
up so i i actually not going to defend
them for that i think it's your own
fault but
the final i think yeah i like i look
back and
i think it was as a spectacle it was
awesome that canterbury wasn't in it
um i remember it was such a huge but
just to build up to it like just the
publicity that it got because it was so
so foreign like you know every every
final was meant to be in christchurch
and cannabis meant to win it and
um the week before we we played
canterbury and i think
what you guys met us with at the start
of the final is probably what we met
canterbury with
in our semi-final and like we were so up
for that semi-final it was just
ridiculous and then
obviously we were up for you guys but i
think what we meant from you guys was
just
like a whole different level to what
we'd experienced that year and
like the intensity that you just played
on the obviously
is that an awesome team but like i think
the energy that the whole region brought
you guys was just
incredible and then yeah like coming out
like
i don't think we're overruled by it all
um i think you know we went up there
like a fever intention to throw the seed
round and um
we just got hit on the nose pretty early
a couple of times and
i'm sure we're going to talk about my
kick in there and cody ray obviously had
an
absolute blinder and yeah like i think
you know there's a few things that you
need to go your way in the final and
kicking's one of them but uh yeah i
remember like i think
chris smiley kicked the ball over bryce
team's head and bryce team ran back and
then it bounced
over and then hughes picked it up and
that was from your own goal line so like
little bits of luck that sort of went
your way early on and then
obviously just the intensity that he's
brought sort of put us in a spot where
we're chasing our tails for a lot of it
and uh
i still remember vaguely like i think we
couldn't remember exactly the time we
had left but i'd say about
five six minutes left and we've just
scored a try
and i think these are up by i'd say five
i think he's kicked off
and we were exiting and uh glenn jackson
called us on a penalty for
one of our players advancing in front of
the kicker probably had i hadn't seen
that call the whole year
and it pops up in the final 30 meters in
front
and cody kicking the way he'd been
kicking he wasn't going to miss so
that was the dagger i think if that
hadn't happened then it would have made
for a hell of a
last five minutes but when they had
about sales that sort of
way any hope of pinching that game and
um
but yeah like i look back on it like
it's one of the ones that's always going
to hurt
like even teammates like fonnie get
stuck into me all the time because he
knows
that that game really hurts me um
honestly i didn't know you'd miss that
many kicks until i talked to fonny and
he has just been to you all the time no
funny i reckon
he's going to have it on his arm that's
how proud of it but he's
he's obviously gutted that we lost but
he's so proud that i missed
so many kicks how many did you make i
don't remember
too many nah i actually i actually can't
remember it would probably be
nice it would be
three or four probably four um but
the only thing like i remember like
because coming from builder like i
i'd never changed like i went from club
rugby i actually played a club game for
reefs in
the year i got selected for tasman so i
went buller
tasman and nothing changed so i never
got
never had any real process to like doing
what i did so before the games
day before the game i wouldn't go kick
at goals or anything i'd just kick
before the game and
the only thing i can really put the
brain farts down to my kicking were
um the night before we went down and
kicked at the stadium
and it's kind of a weird stadium it
always gets well every time i played
there the wind comes in at different
angles and
the night before it was doing one thing
and then the next night it was doing
on game night it was doing something
else so i ended up my head like i had no
coping mechanisms my head was like
like what's this ball going to do and
like i just every time i've gone back
there like i've
gone back there since and it's always
been the same but um
i just wish i learned that i should just
trust just trust
my kicking process because after that
like i think i kicked real well
it's just because the wind was just uh
yeah mentally mentally got me and um
whether that was it or not but um it
just hurts that it was in the final and
yeah i think there's a chant going
around the stadium i don't know if you
started that
the marty's got a bowler chant um i
didn't actually know what they were
saying but
yeah it's sort of always been a
love-hate thing with taranaki every time
i've gone back there there's just been
hate i don't know why like it's always
been
hate like semi-finals finals
just round robin's like there's just
people up there that
just come at someone else you know
there's there's 14 other people on the
field but it's uh
it is it's pretty cool though like um
after the game you go and talk to those
people and
have a laugh so yeah it's all part of
the job
so another moment is this famous moment
where you've
scaled a bear talking about that love
hate relationship what's happened there
they've thrown
a beer at you yeah love hate again the
nike
we went up for the semi-final so when
you said the final it was just noise so
you couldn't hear anything but
the semi-final there weren't as many
people so you could hear everything that
these
these people were saying like just
abusing me like
the game would be stopped and you'd just
be getting abused like no matter what
was going on any chance you got
an ear shot from then they would just be
abusing me and it was just
again like the whole semi-final the
whole final thing again talks but they
were the emotions just sort of
came out i managed to hold on to it the
whole game this time
and uh when i scored the try at the end
of the game the emotions came out and i
just
it was right in front of this group and
i was i probably wanted to give them the
fingers i probably that's
probably what went through my mind was
give them the fingers but you probably
can't do that on uh
on live tv unless you're a jamie booth
yeah yeah see i'm not at their status so
um all i had was a ball so i threw the
bought them and
threw the ball at them well there are
quite a way away because your fields
it's quite a weird field obviously the
cricket ground but i was close enough to
get the ball
at them so i stood up and threw the ball
at them
just in the direction whether it went
into the stand i don't know my arms
aren't big enough so i probably couldn't
get it there but
um yeah so then they threw the beer at
me but went on and
we finished the game but then after the
game you go over and um
they're all shaking your hand and you're
laughing and like
sort of just stuck off water off the
ducks back um so to speak
so but i think that's the best thing
about sort of provincial footy is
whether it's playing for bulla the same
thing happened in bulla like i played
against east coast
and i remember i had this i was kicking
before the game
and there was these uh young kids behind
the post they probably would have been
three or four
and uh they ran off with one of my balls
and uh this lady this lady was just
beside me just laughing at me like
laughing at the fact that this kid had
taken a ball and i like
go get it go get it i was like there's
not a chance like there's not a chance
i'm going to take that ball off
that young kid while i'm in realtoria
like there's not
any chance in hell so i've been copying
flack
from kids adults probably old people as
well like
it's just part of who i am mate and uh
i've got better at handling it
um yeah just the outburst of reaction
sort of get the better of me sometimes
what a tessie career and have we skipped
over
russia one of the craziest yeah russia
russia
russia i think russia was pre-bulla yeah
it was
pre-bulla pre-bullet yeah it was a long
time ago 2011.
um yeah it was uh hey
how old were you sorry i think i was 21
21 when i got there yeah i'm no good
with math but i think it's 21.
um yeah so but yeah brad moore sent me
there
um by chance it's sort of
um just the way it panned out but again
it was sort of i got to a crossroads i
was like well
can't make it in canterbury then went to
north harbour and couldn't make it in
harbour
so i was like stuff it i'll just go
overseas and
do it that way and just have a look
around so but yeah it was it was crazy
russia was
yeah i've talked about it on sky tv but
it's probably
easy to talk about it here because uh
it's not going out to all of new zealand
but russia was just a whole different
ball game like
the sites we've seen like we got we went
to this uh
this area it was um it was owned by the
ceo or something like that it was
it was sort of like just this big open
piece of land that had a few houses on
it
um and it turned out that it was just
like the bosses of the city
like the police like the head of police
and stuff like that whereas it was sort
of like a holiday destination where they
could go
and just get locked into their own gate
so you and i can't just walk on in there
like
unless you've been invited and i
remember going in there and it was just
like ak-47s that we could shoot into the
water
marijuana growing like wildfire it was
it was ridiculous like there was
literally
no rules i guess the only rule was don't
do anything stupid to
harm anyone else and uh yeah it was just
eye-opening like there was
people out shooting like beers and
bringing them back with like their skins
and stuff like this it was just
ridiculous like a lot of the boys that
were there they went back and actually
hunted the beer
um during the winter and stuff like that
so like the options are endless in
russia
um you just got to know the right people
but uh yeah it's uh
it was a great place like it's actually
you think about russia and you're like
why the hell would i go there but to get
the invite like
yeah like if if i was in a better
position rugby wise i definitely want to
go on but
just having the opportunity having the
opportunity
having the opportunity to go somewhere
like that was uh yeah it shaped you as a
person like
yeah you'd be out in a nightclub and you
just have people like looking up and
down like they just want to
dick you and like but it was just
ridiculous like the club
looked after us in a way like there was
always links to the mafia like we've
sort of been told
by other people outside the club that
the club had ties to the mafia and all
this sort of stuff and yeah so it was
sort of
pretty eye-opening like i'd go home and
he said baden phillips so when i first
got there i live with baden phillips he
used to be a half back
um i think he played a bit at new
zealand schools and stuff like that
and uh when i first got there we were
together but he got sent home
so then these mind games started playing
like when he went home i was like locked
in this little
like apartment block and i was like far
out like if i pissed someone off they're
gonna come knock on my door like i was
only 21 like i had no idea what was
going on really
[Music]
so sort of like japan where you can only
have a certain amount of players um
but obviously they they don't have
enough money well at the time they have
enough money in russia to be able to
fund
a heap of foreigners to be there without
playing so they
they sent one home i actually met a guy
called uh rangi he was uh
one of bodhi's good mates he actually
turned up i remember seeing him turn up
and uh
he had bodies all bodies kit on and i
was like far out like this
this guy must be someone but he was just
a sinking animal
and i was just like far out but he met
some absolute legends uh
glenn gregory you know glenn gregory
from tazzy he was over there he was
like the age difference was probably i
think glenn was a few years older than
me so
they were finished like they were they
were done pretty much off their career
and just looking to piss up and
i was still pretty young so i was like
far i can i want to be a professional
grabby player here so when i first got
there i'm not going to drink
but then by the end of it i was verging
on probably an alcoholic so
you either fit in or you get kicked out
so um
yeah but it was crazy that you go some
rugby fields were just like
obviously not a massive sport in in
russia um
you know we play on some real dirt
tracks um
i'm sure you would have seen a few in
your time traveling overseas but
yeah it was just carnage there was no it
was like our stadium had a
green stand and stuff like that but a
lot of steams were just like thrown
together bits of steel and
um but you sort of come back and
appreciate home like it's
yeah i'd go back there though i'd go
back for a holiday i don't know if i'd
go back and play but
i'd go back and have a look around
because once i got there we got no
chance to look really it was just
play rugby go back and so that was the
only sort of downfall but
um probably can't go back now because uh
i think they caught wind of me talking
about the place uh
on sky sport so they probably have a
bounty on my head
i know you've made up a few yarns about
the mafia how
how true are some of those yarns
see this is where it's gonna get niggly
because i actually when i had that
interview when i did the interview i
actually waited because i'd watched you
prank
all the boys i watched you get every
single lad i was waiting for a phone
call i was like
jimmy will probably try to find some
russian person to call me here and
stitch me up on a phone call
i was just like for probably a month
afterwards i was like there's not a
chance if i get a russian phone call
here i'm coming back that heat
and i could end up in a world of hurt
because it could not be yours but
um because because the thing was is
when i did the interview it got posted
in russia
and i got a message from um this rugby
page in russia saying we remember you
marty banks with a wink
and then i woke up and clicked on the
page but the posts had been removed so
obviously someone had told him to take
it down so i started getting a little
bit sketchy about it but um
yeah so like i was like jimmy this is if
jimmy brings me pretending to be a
russian
he'll have me here so i'm just going to
come back i'm just going to come back
with he
but the mafia thing like i was told like
um so we had a grandstand on the
left-hand side of the field
and on the right hand side was the
office block but there was a blacked out
um
literally tinted out room above the
office block
and the only way to get in there was
like there was no steps to it outside it
was just
tunnel like you go on it via a tunnel
and you could just see
obviously with tinted windows you can
still see through them but you don't
know really what's behind them but you
can see
body block people in there and we were
told that this is where
like some of the mafia was sitting like
and it was just like
holy heck about whether they are there
or not i don't know this is just stuff
that we got fed
but um like when you get handed a bag of
cash at the end of your contract
like you start to wonder um yeah they
told me it's because i didn't have my
bank account set up properly but
yeah but uh i'm sure it's all i know the
team now they're sort of in a
second division european comp i think so
obviously a lot of that has to be ironed
out like
um the money side of it but like i'd
turn up to training some days and i'll
just say
i'm not gonna train until i get some
money and i'll bring me this
black or this brown like paper bag and
give me a couple of thousand new zealand
dollars and see me right for
another month or two on the person um
yeah it was just
like no because it said in my contract
that if
if i don't get paid then i don't have to
train so i tell them in the morning at
the gym where i
probably wasn't lifting too much weight
to be fair i was just probably floating
around the gym
ghost-setting it um and i'll just
mention it there and then literally gets
afternoon training
and they just have this piece of paper
to sign and give me some money
and yeah it was just like an ironing
experience like you take for granted
um playing in new zealand your money
turns up on the first and
you've got people that sort of look
after you a little bit in terms of your
rugby contracts and stuff but
yeah without that like being able to
compare where i am now or what i've been
through in new zealand to
where i was in russia like it's just
perspective is crazy
what a what an experience because you
obviously you obviously went by yourself
as a single lad
lots of beautiful russians and you've
always been very good with ladies
i know your beautiful girlfriend listens
to this but any stories
yeah she's uh she hit the jackpot that
michelle did she's uh
she really you know she really reached
for the top of the apple tree and she
she got a nice apple
um so she didn't bottom feed but i
really struggled in russia because uh
the language barrier jimmy
um and i've said this in the past that i
actually hadn't played super rugby then
so
um couldn't use the super rugby card in
russia um
so yeah sort of i just floating on by
mate it's uh
to be fair the other first five that was
there he's a kiwi
um he's come back and he's got a russian
partner um
one of the guys is married to a russian
um
yeah so it was all there i think boogie
horton he's got a russian partner so
i was probably the only ones that didn't
come back were for russian um
michelle was pretty lucky in that
respect so
yeah but no i would have struggled over
there either way mate
well speaking of super ugly let's go to
your super rugby
journey obviously you your first taste
was at the hurricanes
um you were welcomed into my lovely home
and i've got to thank you for i guess
preparing me and my wife
four kids because um looking after you
gave us a good taste it made
i guess made kids a little bit easier um
once we
looked after you so um how was your
super ugly experience
yeah i guess that's probably what yeah
first of all thanks for
taking me under your wing there jabber
but i guess that's sort of where i was
sort of going with the kk and leon stuff
earlier sort of you don't want to talk
too much about it there because
i knew what was coming and in the later
part of the the podcast
i knew the the cane stint wasn't going
to be avoided um
but i think yeah like coming through at
tessie
especially that first year like i said
like our team was so good that
i probably personally didn't experience
uh
too many poor performances though i'm
sure like i said there's some brain
farts throughout the
throughout the games but a lot of them
were pretty hidden because
our team was going so well so as a as an
individual like i think
that year went so well that i probably
set myself up
well for failure at some stage um
because going on what kk said like uh
i clearly wasn't physically ready i was
weaning my way through itm cut because
you can probably get away with it but
once i hit super rugby and uh at this
stage i probably still didn't know
what position i wanted to play um
obviously going to the canes you've got
bodhi
um and uh you're pretty well aware of
where you're sitting the picking order
when you've got someone like bodhi
at 10 so obviously you got
pushed more to fullback alongside
yourself there jeber i think
early on you were injured i'm pretty
sure were you injured early on nah
i was i don't think i was i think you
just got the first crack at 15 and
i remember you doing pretty well for
probably the first five weeks
or so which was a pretty good stint and
then
the famous game down at foresight
i still remember turning out i remember
the first uh pre i knew where i knew i
was in trouble was
first out of preseason we did a i think
it was a yo-yo test
i think that way out like paraparaumu
way past there i think
and then uh we went out to the hard
field session
and it was pissing out of rain and then
we got sent on a massive run around the
waterfront and back and kelly gibbons
was just going like flat out so
just got humped at training did a whole
fitness thing and then another fitness
thing on the end i was like holy heck it
like this is a whole different
ball game lock and that's where i
started thinking like i'm so far behind
the eight ball but then
went to africa and uh yeah like things
went all right like i wouldn't say i set
the world on fire or anything but i
didn't do anything too
too terrible um and then i came back and
i actually
i should blame you for this to be fair
because uh
you're actually meant to start that game
at four sidebar from memory
yeah you're definitely meant to start it
and i think you got you came out because
i was on the bench
and you got withdrawn um with injury i'm
sure of it because i remember
you a lot everlasting words inside my
head were
don't lose that 15 jersey
and like being a young buck like
i didn't really i wasn't really aware of
like what the highlanders game plan was
in terms like all their box kicks and
stuff
but when i got down there and nagi put
every kick
on the button for 45 minutes like
and to this day i still don't think
patrick osborne was even trying to catch
the ball like i just think he was just
jumping at me and like it was just kind
of so i just
and i think that's where mentally like i
wasn't prepared for
like a performance like that like a poor
performance like that i think that was
where kk was sort of
you know like the the mental development
the physical development i just i just
wasn't there and i hadn't
experienced like i said that those poor
performances to
put me in good stead to be able to
manage like a poor start to the game and
i started poor i remember
the kickoff they kicked it the metered
in from touch and i run across to take
it and i nearly took it into touch and i
had to throw it inside to jules and i
was like far out that was close
and i wish that i wish that was the
worst of it because far out it just got
worse
and i just remember like my head was
gone probably
even halfway through the first half like
i just remember i was looking for the
gate
um yeah and like i just i just remember
like offloads and
there's tackles and drop eyeballs like
the list just goes on and
it was just my head was gone so early in
the game that i was destined to
to get hooked pretty early and i think
by looking back like
if i had kk or someone tell me i needed
another year before
obviously i didn't go seek advice so
it's my fault like i didn't have anyone
in my corner like a
an agent at the time that said just hold
off a year like
like i said i was just young seen a
super rugby contract i was like bang
i'm going but looking back now like if i
had
gone and see some advice from kk or leon
they probably would have said
hold off just because they knew i
probably wasn't ready but
the harsh reality is like that game now
as
bad as is looking back like i've never
watched it never watched it
ever but what i learned there about
myself
probably shaped the rest of my career
like like it taught me so much in that
one game like
a lot of guys go into super rugby like
you look at geordie and dmacc and the
young talent coming through now that
just they just transition and go on
through a
smooth sailing but um but when you're a
battler
and yeah and you cop a hard game like
that um especially early on in your
super ob career
it's hard to get back on the horse i
guess like once you have a poor game
you're pretty much
pushed to the bottom of the pile and you
only get another looking unless
we have about 20 injuries so and i was
fine with that side of it but
um like that whole year taught me a lot
like i look back and
like pre-season went all good i was
playing 10 and stuff like that so like
that side was a ride and
like i looked back and the cane's
environment was awesome like i loved
every minute of it i was just
disappointed in myself that
i didn't sort of make the most of that
opportunity would you want to
want to have played the next week if you
were selected or were you pretty keen to
just say oh
i can't i can't handle that at the
moment i think like
that it took me so long like i remember
after that game i remember we stayed
above the casino and uh obviously don't
mind a punt but
i i literally went back to the room and
the boys went out for beers in there i
just remember i still remember sitting
in the room and i was like
i was distraught like i was [ __ ] i
was well gone and
like that next week i probably would my
head probably sort of been wrecked
because
i wouldn't have no coping mechanism i
would have just been probably in a dark
hole that whole week i can't remember
but
it wouldn't have been great like yeah it
probably took me a few
a fair while to come back from that um
and i think
once the season finished um and went
back to tassie
there were still talks that i was sort
of talking to the canes that
i could possibly go back there so they
were talking about there was a contract
to go back and in my head i was like far
out like if i go back there i'm
gonna be in the same position i'll hold
tackle bags um
obviously not gonna look in at ten cause
by that stage i sort of come to the fact
that i'm a 10
after dropping so many high balls but um
and i sort of i remember talking to the
agent because by this time i'd actually
got held of an agent that i've still got
now and i remember saying to him on a
phone call pretty early on
and might mitre 10 cup that i'm pretty
keen to
like try and play myself into another
super rugby team and at the time i had
nothing so
we actually said no to the canes like i
i knocked that back just because
not because i don't want to go back but
like i knew just where i'd sit and i
like the going back there i probably end
up putting more pressure on myself
because i've gone so poorly that
i was always going to be fighting an
uphill battle um so i sort of guess i
bit on myself that
i knew i was better than that and um and
then that year i played for tassie and
we went well again that's the year we
met you guys in the final but
as a whole the season went pretty well
and um i'm sure through
a few words from probably joey wheeler
and shane christian that to the
highlanders
um the highlanders gave me a call and um
asked me to head down there and
to be fair i don't know why the hell
they're looking at me after after they
seen how terrible i went down at the
foresight father the year before so
i was like fast stupid enough to take me
on and give me a chance then they must
see something so
and that's how it came about was brownie
and jamie joe and
um yeah jerry wheel on that so yeah
going down there like
yeah the harsh reality of the year
before put me in better stead
going down there so and how did you find
it down there what was the difference
yeah i think going down there like i i
knew sops was there and i knew
quasi parker were there and uh but i
think at the time
like as a 10 and even like lima would
have admitted to like
he was pretty up and down with his
performances at that level and
i remember the year before he was sort
of up and down but he sort of had that
luxury of being able to get him weak out
because he was sort of the number one
dog there and
um i remember going down there and i
knew lee was still the
the number one team like i was under no
illusions that that's how it was and me
and quasi were going to fight for the
bench spot but
i sort of just sensed an opportunity
that we could probably push lima and
steph
see if we could um get a bit more game
time and start off alright jamie joe
called us in and
pretty much told us what really no
lima's here you're here because of you
and
down the bottom and we're like sweet
airs but round one
um stop started um he got part of the
game and
um i remember jamie joe like i was none
otherwise jamie joe came up to me
straight after the game he's like you're
starting next week
and i was like how can you put software
just got part of the game i'm like and i
was i'm good mates of sops and
at the time it's like you can't pull
stops out and give me a start when he
just got part of the game and but then i
found out that sops actually had a
family thing he had to go away to so
we played the reds and i got part of the
game so i was like
um i was like [ __ ] this this could be a
50 50 go here like
if i can just keep chipping away at
stops here i might be able to push my
way in but
from that point on like sops just went
bang and
his year was just ridiculous i think he
got play of the year for
the super rugby and just doing
willy-nilly stuff that
brownie was telling him to do like over
the head chips and
like when he got guys like that in front
of you doing stuff like that you just
got to sit back and just say fair play
but just the environment was it was
awesome like i'd like to think that
quasi and i
sort of helped lima i know go
to the next level a little bit obviously
not just us but having a little bit of
pressure on his tail
like you could just see him build into
that season like you never put in a
bare performance so like it was just one
of them years you just
take your head off and and shake his
hand and
sit behind him and try and pick up any
minutes so yeah and
yeah but the the whole highlanders
environment just suited me down to the
ground like
obviously love the beer um can't drink
many of them but love the beer
um joey obviously had a field day with
me with his highlanders tv stuff but
just the way the whole like you're here
to work but as soon as
the work's finished you can go and enjoy
yourself and i think that sat pretty
well with
our whole our whole group like where
they even misfits down there that just
gelled early on and
probably didn't deserve on paper or
anyone's opinion to go the way we did
but just the way we went about our work
just
the way the boys enjoyed themselves away
from rugby but obviously
got flogged at training it just it just
built a culture that was pretty awesome
to be a part of
and you spoke about minutes there and
you obviously played some pretty
important minutes at the business end of
the season
coming on with what maybe 15 20 to go
guiding the highlander's side to super
ragna victory
with a drop goal this makes up for all
your
miss kicks and tyranny i wish it was 15
or 20 minutes it felt like 80 minutes
no i don't even know how it was probably
11 and a half i reckoned but
i don't know how long
actually i don't know exact number but
it wasn't many stops never really left
me with too many [ __ ] it was 11 and a
half
you could probably look it up it could
be i'm actually not sure but it wasn't
too much more or too much less but
like i said like the whole year i
remember coming on throughout the end of
the games and
you only really set up for failure when
you come on with that much times ago
like
you can't really do too much good but
you can actually like ruin the game
so so like the whole year i was sitting
on that pine and i was just like far out
that's
you pretty much looking at the clock and
you're looking uh there's a 20 minute
mark to go you're doing fitness at the
end of the game no matter what and that
was always the
there was a real dagger because you sit
there like oh i'm not on yet
but i haven't got to the fitness mark
but as soon as it laps you're just like
ah
[ __ ] this like i'm gonna run shuttles
after this but
um no not after the final no
i did my best to sneak away from a few
throughout the season
when we pinched a couple of games we'd
managed to avoid
the trainer which was ideal but now the
final was
yeah again like i going back to the cape
town hold it
held a few obviously daunting memories
um
yeah but going back there it was that
was carnage that was
like the mitre 10 cup final on on
steroids like
that environment running out even just
in a bench i was just like holy heck
like sitting on the pine great place to
be and just hearing like the noise and
just
like there's so much energy in that
stadium and the game was just going back
and forth
and i i got to the point with like
halfway through the second half i was
like i ain't getting on here like
there's not a chance like
so i was just sitting there enjoying the
spectacle and then bloody stops
pulled up tight with his hamstring or
something i was like oh i'm on here so
sink or swim with freaking four-point
supplements i was hoping stops would
give me a bit more of a lead but
um but yeah and i still remember the
first play where i came on
he's had a 20 meter line out and i was
like the bus is coming here the bus
is coming and i was like holy heck let's
get mentally prepared for this
and then uh we had the the play where we
didn't attack you
we didn't attack your maul and i think
we came around and got a penalty and i
was like thank you
the more we spent down the indy like
your half was uh
it was it was a godsend but um yeah i'll
still never forget roscoe not scoring
that try it uh
i would have liked him just to dot that
ball down and and pretty much put the
game to bed but uh
it just played out the way it did and
big old buff comes over with bodhi and
and stops a prop meter out from the line
but yeah
and then obviously what happened after
that was yeah because
we didn't really practice the drop goal
in training we'd
kick drop goals after training just with
our own pressure between me and stops
but
hadn't done it in a game setting so i
don't think we actually work through the
process of how we're going to go about
it no because you had a few cracks in it
i remember you dummying a couple and i
was like oh yes
banksy's choking no no no i wanted to
get rid of them but
i didn't have anyone else around me like
everyone was so tired that everyone was
in front of me
and before i was kicking the ball i was
like you have to be certain that this
you're going to get this kick away like
if it misses it's sweet but you don't
want to get charged down here because
like you don't want to be that guy that
gets charged down and they score under
the sticks and you lose by
three or four points whatever to be
three points so like i could just see
kolsey and tj like they were every rock
they just sit beside the rock
and as soon as nuggie touched the ball
they were just gone
both feet and i was just like oh no not
this one
and then not the next one and then the
one that we didn't actually try and
like plan in any way like it caught you
off guard a little bit so
gave me a bit of time so i wanted to get
it away on the first two but
it was just in the back of my head like
this could go terribly wrong if this
gets charged down because
no one was going to chase back it would
have been game set and uh
probably would have had you yelling at
me again so don't need that too many
times in my life i'm gutted i didn't get
into
earlier now that i heard about what what
effect
i've been asked so many times who the
worst people are in rugby
and you and crap 100 without a doubt
like yeah it's just and after living
with you like
i know it's just rugby like and you
obviously talk a lot of [ __ ] like and
that's why i probably don't want to come
on the podcast because i was a bit
worried about what might come up but
like just having to deal with you
constantly um
yeah it was it was tough work but i had
a little downstairs dungeon there so
used to sneak off and get away from you
and not so much bribery
priebu was awesome but more so you
but anyway that that ball just sailed
through the uprights
you win super rugby what a moment how
are those celebrations
yeah i remember we sat on your your uh
the other changing [ __ ] for hours were
in there i wouldn't even know what time
we left but
yeah it was absolutely awesome when we
went back to the the hotel
and it was a bit of a blur like a bit of
a shame like
i didn't realize because i was so naive
or immature i guess to
how it all works i guess like i thought
we'd go back and just be the team so all
my family was up there but they'd all
gone home to beard
um but when we got back to the hotel we
had families and stuff there i was like
far out like
it would have been cool just had my
family there but by the time i messaged
they were all tucked up so
looking back at that it was you know you
sort of would have been cool to spend it
with your family but
um to have them at the game was pretty
awesome um
but then the celebrations were it was
just endless like
you won a trophy like that i'm sure you
would have experienced
but you look at it every day you turn up
to any of you do
and it just lifts your spirits a little
bit and just gives you a little bit of
energy and
in time and need so like we had it on a
i think
game was on a saturday and we got to
thursday night
and we didn't have the trophy but we got
our manager to drop us off drop it off
to us and
as soon as it came through the door the
energy level just came up and like we
found another day and
it was just yeah it was just embraced by
everyone like i think
like i've sort of talked about it like
it
when the crusaders won the final it's
sort of
it's pretty common um like when you won
your first title with the canes it would
have been
you know embraced for the community like
massively so in dunedin like
so many people have been waiting like 20
years for that that trophy to turn up
in the center of dunedin and when it
turned out like the response from the
public was just
like ridiculous like yeah like we went
around and
like grown men crying and it was just
at the time you didn't realize what
you'd done but like that was sort of
pretty
pretty humbling when you're seeing like
just so much emotion just
for a rugby trophy you know and and it
meant so much to the community so
that was pretty cool to sort of bring
that bring that down and
um obviously tony brown what year was
that i don't actually know what year
that was the party at tony browns that
didn't eventuate sort of eventuated a
bit later
yeah and then so obviously you moved off
to traviso but
are you signed with teresa but you
didn't actually go so
was that the following year what
happened there i think i signed in
2016 uh i think it was
pretty sure off top of my head but it
was sort of early on
in the super rugby season i think uh
yeah so
like it's when it first happened like it
was um
it was it was a lot to do at the time i
didn't want to like once i
sat on it for a couple of months i
shouldn't have signed this contract but
when i signed up the old lady was
actually crook and i was
like she was sick of some cancer and i
lost the plot like
i was pretty much on autopilot for
probably a month like
um the the highlanders didn't even know
the only person that knew was the doctor
and i didn't actually know that the
coaches didn't know so
um i went to the doctor and we were
dealing with all this stuff i was seeing
a sports psych and stuff like that
all behind closed doors and i just
thought naturally the coaches would know
and uh
got to like a month into pre-season like
the the second half of preseason and the
coaches come up and they set me in this
room
and they're like what's going on mate
like you are terrible and i was like
and i i just remember i was i've done
some stupid [ __ ] like i've signed this
contract
uh mum's crook and they're like what do
you mean your mom's crook i was like
mum's got cancer and they're like oh
like we didn't know this and stuff like
so
but once that all happened like um it's
not so much that
i loved italy once once i got there but
at the time i was like i shouldn't
assign this contract
so just because i wasn't in the right
headspace and i hadn't really thought it
through that well and
the more it said on my mind i've got to
get out of this like
it just doesn't sit well with me and um
we tried we tried breaking the contract
and we managed to knock it down to one
year
um but yeah like i said like
once i got over there i actually loved
italy but
so it wasn't so much that italy as a
whole it was just at the time when i
signed a contract i just recruited it
um yeah and uh yeah just one of those
things that
um i probably wish i had a bit more
guidance around i sort of panicked into
a
this decision like i wasn't getting
heaps of game time at the
at the landers um and i just sort of
thought i was sitting behind a brick
wall again so
there was a reason why i signed it but
just wasn't that well thought through
um and just sort of first contract they
got put in front of me i signed which
probably wasn't smart was it a money
thing that wanted made you want to go
over there
or what was it about that um i think
like italy when i was looking like
obviously a beautiful country but yeah i
think i sort of thought i hit my
obviously we'd um
done what we've done with tesman
obviously hadn't won the final but um
gone and won a super rugby final
um and at the time i was like like this
is probably where i sit in the picking
order like it sops is here
like i'm probably not going to get much
more game time like i didn't really want
to float around to another super ugly
team if there was an opportunity just
because
like i wasn't really copped a lot of
slack about um
jumping around teams like when i was
younger and stuff so i was like the only
thing for me to do now is to to head
overseas so that was sort of the thought
process like
all i ever wanted i guess was um to have
a crack at super obvious
trying to see how i went with minutes
under my belt and i was at that time i
just wasn't getting it
and the minutes i was getting i was
going all right but just wasn't
warranting enough to
knock someone like stops off as perch
which i completely understood so
um and that's just the way rugby goes
sort of time and
timing's a lot of it um some boys fall
into a spot and
they nail that timing and they pick up
minutes from word go but
um obviously running into bodhi and then
stops probably until the better tens of
recent times that have
pulled on the jersey and super rugby is
uh just part and parcel of it
so then with um chavezo what did you do
once you
got out of that contract for a year yeah
so
um so i went back i think i went up to
tessie
and literally just spent time with the
family
and then i remember we we managed to
reduce it down to a year because i
actually missed the cut-off date so if i
had it turned up
i think it was november or something i
missed the qualification for
um the champions i can't even put the
heineken cup or whatever like i wasn't
technically qualified because i wasn't
in the country
so treviso they're pretty good like once
i explained what had gone on with marmon
or that they're pretty good like they
they could have been real um [ __ ]
about it
and just forced me into it but they said
look we'll we'll meet halfway and
we'll knock it down to a year contract
and when that happened
um i think hayden parker did his mcl
um or something like that at training at
highlanders and
literally a week later i got a call from
brownie and
i was back down to the landers for for
another year and uh
and i think that's the year like i
remember that's and then obviously
stops got injured pretty early on in the
season so finally got the minutes i was
looking for
obviously with a with an end date of
having to go to italy but
like being able to play that season and
get consistent minutes like i just felt
my game
like the confidence and everything just
grow and like that's all i was looking
for
at tazzy i had that like you go you get
your minutes you'd have some poor games
yeah some [ __ ] kicking experiences like
the experience but as a whole you can
work your way through that because you
get minutes under your belt and
the bad games are few and far between
but getting it
at super rugby and be able to play i
don't know most of the season
um starting at 10 was yeah it was a real
confidence booster for me and
um like a year that i'm i look pretty
fondly on obviously we didn't win the
final or anything or
or make the final but as a person and as
a personal experience like it was
yeah pretty good for me and you
obviously took that form
straight over to italy and started
carving out up for travis am i right
yeah went to italy and um got over there
and we started playing like we had a few
months a month or sort of training
before the season started
and i remember we played monster away
and i i knew i was sick
like i knew i thought i was just
homesick i was like like because
everything was under my head like i
didn't want to be there at the start
like i was so against
i just for this whole year just built up
in my head there i i didn't want to be
going there
um not so much about italy like i said
it was just i'd given up on the whole
the whole contract in my head and went
over there pretty
negatively minded like towards it all um
so i got over there
felt like i was homesick so i was just
like just toughen up like just go
go train and play and i remember playing
munster and
i knew i wasn't right and uh then we
played the next game
and then they took random blood tests
off me and i was like they're like you
feeling all right i was like no i feel
like absolute [ __ ]
and they're like oh your bloods have
come back and you've got glandular fever
and i was like oh like i've i've been
crooked for probably five weeks
and i'd actually come to the back end of
it like i'd sort of gone through the
the worst part of it but um so it wasn't
a great start to the
to the um competition there but once i
came right then
um i think we actually went on a bit of
a winning shoot there with treviso which
was
pretty cool i think we at the time i
think we went on their
longest winning streak which wasn't huge
at the time but the small wins you know
i think it was
five or six or something like that so
the club was uh on a bit of a high and
you could sort of
you could sort of feel the club was had
changed from the year before like the
year before the club was getting hidings
and you could see that year that sort of
transitioned into less hidings and then
now they've
pushed on and been pretty pretty
consistent except for this year i think
i've copped a few this year but between
me leaving and
and this year they've gone pretty well
so it was in a building phase like
once i settled in and and actually
started appreciating that i was there
and like
enjoying the environment like it was
actually really good kieran crowley was
an awesome coach i think he's a taraneki
led um
yeah so like being alongside him and he
was awesome like he
like i remember going into the first
meeting and it could have been terrible
like i just met the guys
they knew i didn't turn up for my
contract like i said some
pretty terrible stuff like i had to tell
karen on the phone that i didn't want to
play for him or his club like
i had to try and get this point across
that i didn't want to go to italy so all
this would have been repeated through
the club so
in my head i'm flying over to this place
where like
there's going to be absolute hate for me
and i got in there and they
they were awesome like i remember being
in the meeting and they
took the piss out of me and said oh
we've had a guy that owes about
a hundred thousand dollars in fines
because he hasn't turned up to training
for a year and everyone pissed
themselves and
shook my hand and and that was it like
it was yeah it could have been a
terrible experience but i think they
they sort of
took me in there and um yeah i apologize
to the club and said it wasn't so much
about them but
um but looking back like italy is an
awesome place like you've been there
um yeah obviously you know different
clubs but
yeah benetton was a cool experience how
did you find the lifestyle and
did you get it any um any good at
italian
i tried learning italian we had it we've
got a plastic italian
um in the team his name's sid yeah
so he's placed it the italian national
team now but we used to go and trial and
italian
um we were horrific he's been there for
much longer than me and it
knows nothing um yeah and oh
yeah my mental capacity in terms of
learning new things
is terrible so like my money hongo
i probably know more nihongo than i did
in italy
just because i've probably been in the
in the grapevines here for
for a couple of years but uh yeah i'm
terrible at learning new things mate so
um i know your brother your brother's
really struggling with the language too
so
i'm pretty happy about that that's good
and then um
so how did the treviso thing finish was
it just a
massive million dollar yen contract in
japan that got you out of there or were
you always
just sign for your visa a certain amount
of time
um nah so when the stuff was gone off
marmot
when i signed that contract um
in all honesty like i was actually
trying so if we did manage to
stop the italy contract and i went
through my thought process better like
i wanted to end up in japan after it
also before i went to italy i knew
it was just to go over there sort of
pay my dues with my contract and then
hopefully transition into japan so the
whole thing was
um to eventually end up in japan just
closer to home like especially when mom
was sick so mum was still sick when i
was in italy
but the flight was just huge like i
remember i came back for joe wheeler's
wedding
and it took like a day and a half to get
back and um
just a huge effort to get back so with
mum being sick like
japan was just the the easiest place to
be
being out like having the access to get
home so only a 10 hour flight before
covert obviously
without um isolation but so that was the
whole process around it was like if mum
did get really sick there
i could uh just nip home at the drop of
a hat so
um but japan's awesome like it's uh
obviously pretty isolated like
when you're over here you would have
been here with bribry and that but
that's the hardest thing i guess for me
is
coming over here without the partner
michelle and
just going to training and sort of being
on that like i said that auto
autopilot going to training coming home
and that's pretty much your life until
you get a day off
and uh i'm lucky that tojo and that are
here now we've got a decent crew of
foreigners that
we sort of get out and about a little
bit have a few beers and stuff like that
so it breaks up that
that cycle a little bit um yeah so the
plan was michelle was going to be over
here
after the olympics which was meant to be
obviously
um well last year last year yeah last
year it's all floated by so she has
meant to be over
after the olympics um obviously with
covert that pushed it back a year
so now she's obviously wanting to do the
reporting at the olympics this year so
she has to stay in new zealand so it's
sort of
everything's just been pushed back so in
a perfect wheel she would have been over
and
would have been just chipping away as a
couple here but just have to take it on
the chin and
just succeed that's the way out of the
world at the moment yeah
and then um obviously last year was
pretty tough oh your
your first year with the red hurricanes
was obviously successful you got
promoted
beat the poor red sparks in the
promotion relegation
but then last year um was obviously an
extremely tough year you want to talk
about
both of those seasons yeah obviously the
first year was
when so when i signed we were still in
the top league
and uh i think that the boys actually
had their best year
in the top league but the way the system
worked
they still had to play a playoff game
and again they probably should
it was against you guys it might have
been i think i think
i think had lost all their games and
then they won one game at the end and
survived
yeah so i think the boys like had their
best year
then they lost the coat got relegated so
i came over and sort of knew where we
sat
went through the year and it was sort of
our whole year was built up to literally
whoever we met in the promotion game
whether it was you guys or
just whoever it was like it was sort of
what our whole season was based around
and
so the first season was it wasn't great
for us because we didn't get
um really pressured too much from other
teams until
until we played use and then obviously
transitioned into the top league but
so we sort of floated through that year
and a lot of our flaws and that were
hidden because we weren't playing good
teams so
we sort of we're in this fairy tale that
our team was okay like
if we get promoted here would be sweet
so then we played you guys
and i think we're actually pretty lucky
i think he's got a yellow card or a red
card
i think from memory and i think he's had
us under the pump and
when he's got there we sort of got our
noses in front and then got a bit of
confidence and
ended up winning that but which is
unreal like the club like
like i said like that the people just
went nuts at our club that they
thought it was the best thing ever but
what we didn't realize was
we're putting ourselves in a position to
to go up
to go up to top league and that was
hands down like
the hardest season even though it got
cut short like it was only a handful of
games but it was the hardest thing
like i've ever sort of been a part of
like our boys were trying like
uh like the boys would just they got
massive hearts like they'll go flat out
they'll train hard
but we just didn't have like the systems
we didn't have
the personnel to compete with teams like
gobe and that like
um we went from second division to to
the top division with
the second division team and like it's
there's a massive gap like there's a
massive gap
in top league from the top teams to the
bottom teams and then we were
coming from further down than that so we
were obviously went through that season
and
at the end of the season we thought oh
yeah we'll we'll be right and we'd sort
of played a few preseason games when we
gone okay
and we thought oh you're like the
transition might not be too bad
but the way our season was structured we
got met with pretty much the top three
teams
pretty much back to back to back and we
had injuries
um like our big forwards were injured
like we lost liam squire pretty early
like
we just had smaller guys going against
bigger guys with
unbelievable skill like we're playing dc
and
brody retalic and guys like that like
the japanese
like the japanese international players
were all in these top teams so like
we were just out there trying our
hardest but just getting absolutely torn
to bits and
um things needed to change like it was
just a personnel thing like
um just needed guys that could come in
and
help coach the boys that are here and
then obviously add some size and
and stuff like even now like we're still
not a big team and we've brought in
like these decent-sized boys we're still
going to be
in relation to the top teams a pretty
small team so but
that year was just like 97 points is
like like i remember kobe they scored
like their last try and they were
rushing the kick to try to get another
like another minute and to break the
hundred and i was just
yeah it's like i just felt for the boys
like i was just like
um yeah it was it was disheartening like
because you sort of grow pretty close to
the the japanese boys and like after the
game and that like
they were so gutted like because they're
so passionate about everything they do
like the company means everything to
like the boys in the group
so to see them so hurt like it was just
losing was hard but then going into the
changing sheet and seeing the boys like
so down it was just
yeah and then we next week i think we
played yamaha and then we got
like 70 or something like it was just
like the boys
it was like me and the in the highland
uh when we played the highlanders like
my head was gone
and the moment we played kobe i think
all the heads the boy's heads just went
south and we just we couldn't come back
to it and
we were saved by covert to be fair like
yeah it was um
it would have been pretty hard to get
off the canvas it must have been good
for your tackling practice was it that
season
no i think like so obviously it's 10 you
spend a lot of time in the backfield so
like
there's just like 10 people i was just
my tackling didn't get any better like
it's
it highlighted it highlighted it more
than anything
oh how good what a career that's
stones and glass houses too by the way
boy like i don't know how i haven't come
at you like i think
in my head it's just been about me but
you are not the best you cannot be
throwing [ __ ] like that like yeah
this is your podcast come on we're
talking about you
and your daddy yeah yeah
but honestly though banksy what a career
you've played for that many teams
uh jeez you would have seen some sites
and you've started almost every team
you've been
in you wouldn't have thought this sort
of 13 14 years ago
as the skinny kid coming out of bulla
that you would have played
for the teams that you have and had the
success that you have had so
um yeah what an awesome career so what's
what's next what's next for big marty
banks after this season
yeah i guess uh my contract ends this
year so a lot of it depends on what
happens with that like
whether i was in japan or whether i'm
venturing back home i'm not too sure but
i've always been pretty keen on um like
tezi obviously
it's it's been a lot like with bulla and
it's meant a lot to me
ever since i played for tassie like it
was that's probably the hardest thing
about leaving new zealand was
leaving that group and leaving that team
because like like you know like being a
part of that group is
is pretty special like it's uh yeah like
it's a real community feel and
um obviously they gave the first chance
to
have a crack at professional footy and
um so for me personally like
i'd love to be able to earn the chance
to probably the right person to talk to
at the moment earn the chance to come
back
and and play 50 games um but for me like
if i
if i get the chance to do that i'd like
to say i want to
be able to play my way into that jersey
and not just hit up a coach and say can
i sneak in your back door for
for a couple of games like yeah so um
because sort of tez has progressed so
much
throughout the years like back in the
day that's probably her at work you
could probably
flick a message and get a gig but now
like the boys that are coming through
like the
environment and just the way teddy's run
now is just
you know it's getting to the point where
it's nearly world-class and
um yeah so like to get back into that
group it's definitely got to be
earned for me and then the other one
would be obviously to play for bulla
at some stage um would be awesome but
outside of that like i've got no real
plans uh me and fonnie had sort of
speculated a tiling business there yeah
he gave it a good shout out on his
podcast
he's talking about it's gone pretty
quiet he's moved back to christchurch
and
um he's fallen in love so
the phone calls are getting less and
less between me and fonz which is a bit
unfortunate but
yeah i think if something like that
happens i think it'd definitely have to
be
at the right time i think like if i go
back at the end of the season then
as you know there's that transition
period where you probably need a little
bit of a break
and finally's probably going through
that now but i think i'll have to clear
my head a little bit if i went back and
if this was the last contract you know
so um but yeah what happens i guess
and this is obviously in auckland um
we've got a house up there so
probably be rude rude if i didn't go
back there
after being in japan for so long so um
yeah we'll
see what what doors open up when i get
back sure about the body's feeling good
yes you still feel like you've got a few
more
years left than you yeah i think so like
uh like
i've been in plain rugby for a while but
haven't had many minutes jimmy so
haven't been beaten up too much yet so
yeah i think i've still got a couple of
years but
obviously that'll be uh determined by if
someone picks me up or not or if docomo
keep me on but
time will tell me man i'm sure clubs
will be racing to have you on their book
especially after this
knowing what what a lead you are but
anyway
as always we've gone to our instagram
for some questions
and as you could imagine plenty have
come through you're
you're a character that people love and
um
a character that people love to hear
from
so a lot of them is about um the same
sort of stuff
we've already talked about um fonita's
always
he's come up chance with the first one
would you give up your
super title title to kick
every kick in the final verse the neck
ah he's uh this is probably the part
that i was treating because i've seen
this question thrown out to so many
people obviously on previous podcasts
and
i can only imagine what's possibly come
through but fonnie has
um always asked me this question
and it's uh it's nearly it's impossible
to ask like i've always said on the
fence like
being a part of the highlanders group
and being part of tessie is like
there's not much between them and
obviously what it meant to dunedin to
win that trophy and what it means to the
group we're a part of and what we sort
of
did that year and around that time was
huge
but then looking at the teddy side like
i could
it's it's the hardest question probably
the hardest question that fonnie has
ever asked me and it's not an
intellectual thing he just knows that
i'm torn between
the two teams and like i can't sit on
one side of the fence because
i can't win with the question i would
say i would say
i would say i wouldn't because like the
experience i had by winning with the
highlanders group was massive and
i still get a lot of enjoyment like when
tassie wins like
yeah it was like brought me to tears the
first one they won
um just seeing the boys uh win that comp
so
knowing that teddy's won their final i'm
stoked so i can be pretty sort of
content
and also if you did kick all your goals
it doesn't guarantee that you would have
won that game either you
you never know what would have happened
is that's the only thing about
100 so i think you're right
okay next question
um does he really have ebola
this must be from one of the next one on
the meki
no i've only had glandular fever um i
don't think i had a bowler
i'd say why sucky probably started that
chant um
but yeah he he was into me after that
final because obviously
him and myself and a couple other boys
went down that year and the whole
preseason was just
relentless chat from him like he's
probably quite
human but for some reason he just gets
stuck into
any chance he got he gets stuck into me
and uh yeah i'm just waiting for that
one chance i don't know when it'll be
but where i can get him back oh you'll
get him
okay is it true you were next in line in
the rugby world cup 2011.
this is yeah i've heard about this next
one in 2011.
i don't even think i i think i went on
the piss the night before because i just
got back from russia
i was actually in auckland um but i was
hungover on the final day
and i actually i think i was on a couch
just parked up watching it sort of be no
good but no there's definitely no chance
i'll be anywhere there
i couldn't even get off the couch to go
celebrate it i wasn't there i was that
dusty
okay what's your worst tackle attempt
there's a few
questions about tackling
the worst tackle attempt oh
i've been steamrolled by nani ah
i still that's the one thing like that's
probably the one thing that
nani nani and sita like nani it's not
that there's not much between them two
to be fair but the one game at the cape
town
where he's been a 4-2 i think but nani
was
not he went to the fulbright position
and i wasn't actually i wasn't
meant to be in the i that's when you
don't do rips of training i should have
been on the other side of the scrum
and i think our midfielder was meant to
be a cross and i just remember being
when that scrum went down i'm not meant
to be here and i looked up seen nuns
and i was like the only chance like i've
got this
going pear-shaped for the canes is if tj
runs this too much
but tj just went straight from the deck
and nan said like 10 meters between
me and him and every time i played nuns
it was just he was coming over top of me
like
straight at me and uh he obviously i
waited for the steamroll but
he uh went in and out and then bendy got
the steam roll so
i felt so bad for bender because i
remember looking back and i was just
like oh i'm sorry bender
and i felt so [ __ ] for that
since that game but nothing like
i've taken a lot of solace in the fact
that bodhi went to the blues this year
last year and played against the canes
and bodhi obviously will play out of the
year
like well above my level like obviously
chalk and cheese between me and him but
to see nani do it
twice in the same game to bodhi no one
can
ever give me [ __ ] about it now because i
can just sit and say
happened to bodhi like that that is like
it's not
i know it's not great great way to look
at it but that's the way i'm going about
it
boat oh good how did you train
when you were growing up what was your
training routine like
how did i train my training was i was
always
i was always pretty fit like i was um
it was sort of my safe haven but me and
the gym had a love hate
relationship like i can't say they got
into a gym probably until
the canes and i wish i wish i wish i did
earlier because
gee i needed it but as a kid like i just
relied
on other sports like i always sort of
just relied on my fitness because i knew
i wasn't big
didn't think i could ever get big and uh
the gym was just hard work for that age
so i always found excuses when i was
younger but
but now like i actually don't mind it i
accept it as part of part of the job and
put on a few kgs i actually went over a
hyundai during coronavirus
i've dropped back down to a more happy
happy space
of mid-90s so um but yeah training man
me and johnny don't really get along
fair enough um was screech off save the
bow your first
inspiration first inspiration
faria that nickname that was the
county's game and
sumo got me hooked my eye he just he
pretty much ruined me as a person
because
i've looked back i looked exactly like
screech my hair was exactly the same
like i'm sure screech probably wore a
big jersey
skinny as heck like i was a dead ringer
i'm just gusted it got announced on
public tv where everyone could just sort
of catch on to it normally you get the
odd nickname where
in the team environment and it just
stays in the team environment but this
one was
this is public and uh yeah it's still
with me to this day
oh bloody good the people still call you
screech
yeah hear him there yeah yeah
okay next question why does martin
always smell like mud
why does martin always smell like mud
who's that come from
lima sopawanga limus
oh no because what happens is
what happens is if you have a bet with
someone
me and stop's had a few bits of training
and you become a pig because
you don't pay up on your bets and sops
to this day still owes me a handful of
bets because
it was dinners it was all sorts of stuff
and he has tried putting it on me that
i'm a little peak
and uh about my previous behaviors but
yeah it sort of it was sort of his fault
because um he didn't pay up on his bits
[ __ ] okay marty tell us the story how
you thought you pulled off the big play
with george
georgie crawford
who's that from this is from big sam
casey no sam casey like
i see there's like i said there's two of
you that i don't really want to pick up
phone calls from that's you and joe
wheeler
but then there's just one person that
i've just got no respect for and that's
sam
casey none at all like i've helped that
guy out
many times like when i was at the
landers like i'd help him out
went to cup day like put him up an
accommodation like
pretty much just held his hand a lot of
times like through our friendship
and then the one chance he knew where i
had no idea
who this girl was he just absolutely
dominated me like it was like it was
carnage really i was
pissed off of him but i knew by the time
i got to the date
i knew it was a setup well i felt like i
knew it was a setup because joe wheeler
was just being too coy about it all
um but i didn't have the guts to walk
out on the date because i was like hang
on a minute like
she's not bad so i was just like let's
just go to the date but then it
backfired immensely
like so what was it was hidden camera
and stuff
yeah just like they so i've been to lone
star
countless times so as you know i don't
cook much so every wednesday would
normally
every no every day off we'd sneak down
to lone star and
get a half price feed but we never ever
sat
in the rest like we'd always sit in the
restaurant you'd never ever get put
out in the bar especially midweek
because it wasn't busy enough
and i remember we went in i hadn't made
a booking because i'm useless like i
didn't even cross my mind to ring up and
book a table i was just like we'll just
turn up so we'd organize the time and
stuff
and uh she actually chose lone star and
i was like
i don't want to go to lone star because
i knew the boys would be there
but now i was like my 50 discount so i
was like sweet you you you
sort of respect that side of it because
you're tied up
but uh but but like i said like i didn't
make it booking but when we got into
this restaurant
and the bar they're like i will we'll
take you in here
and we're right in the middle of the bar
the table was set with like
two knives and forks each side like a
napkin and stuff i was like why is this
set because i haven't i haven't booked
this like
and why are we in the public bar like
get me out the back so i'm a bit hidden
here i was
like everything was just starting to
come to fruition
i knew i was in a wheel to hurt here and
then this lady come over she took our
order
then another lady came over and she
wanted to take her order i was like what
like why is all these people
and then the owner came down because i
was mates of the owner and he was like
in his socks i was like why are you down
here in your socks like
just went on and then obviously we're
sitting where they put us
the security camera was right above our
table just looking down
straight into the table and it was just
like
it was well planned like hats off to
them like they they did bloody well but
seeing joe wheeler's face and sam
casey's face i just wanted to punch them
square in the jaw
not so much like i wasn't actually
gutted about the date being a flop i was
just gutted that they had got me
and that was yeah that was the hardest
thing to swallow have you spoken to her
since
yeah i think i bumped into her every now
and then i sort of have a laugh about it
but
you come across a lot of inmates or
people in the standing there and they're
like how's georgie you know
obviously you just can't really respond
to it because you know everyone's seen
it on youtube so it's like well
what can i say to you mate like good on
you
oh classic okay um
best sporting event that you have ever
attended as a spectator
this sporting event um
went to the melbourne cup there's a bit
of a flop she's pissing down with rain
um this sporting event
i don't think i've actually been to many
to be fair watched a lot of rugby games
from the sideline
i'd say the super rugby fine i was a
spectator there for most of it
um no i actually
i actually don't think i've been too
many i've just been to cricket and stuff
but there's nothing spectacular happen
but
yeah i'll just go off the super rugby
final didn't you go to the um joseph
parker fight
oh yeah went to the joseph but no that
was terrific didn't enjoy that
no i went yeah yeah that was probably my
worst experience because uh
i don't know what that was on a saturday
i think but i got to cardiff on the
friday
who asked this question is this funny
again no
so now i went to yeah joseph parker and
i got pissed
all night the night before and oh you
were there
yeah and then the next day i was a
zombie like i was in a world of hurt
like i wanted nothing to do with the
fight i got to the fight
knocked over some poor guys i was
walking in i was pretty much asleep
kicked over some guys drink your four
beers and it takes about
50 50 minute 50 to an hour just to get
the beers like
this poor bloke was distraught so i had
to go back up and wait the whole time
for his beers
and now i just sat down pretty much over
here between my legs just
watching the rounds tick over and then
as soon
as soon as the fight finished i was out
i didn't even like at the time i was i
don't care who wins it's fine like even
if joseph parker wins this it's still
not going to get me up off the camp
off the canvas i'm still no good like um
and then i heard the night out
afterwards was absolutely amazing but
i didn't want to borrow it so okay next
question
um how does puresport cbd help you from
grayson heart
yeah i've actually uh actually got some
of the
fine stuff here yeah uh actually use
your discount code there
jimmy you're probably the one thing
you've probably the one thing you've
ever done for me that's been positive
but no it's actually good i've got some
oil here somewhere too
um we've just ordered another batch tojo
and i so
i'm just waiting for that to turn up but
yeah it's good stuff i never thought um
i'd ever take some cbd but sort of bit
skeptical on it but um
it's been awesome yeah good to hear good
to hear some good feedback
yeah bloody good you've answered you've
answered a lot of these
how did you become a goat that's that's
come up
how twice actually become a no chance in
hell
no chance an hour ago maybe i think i
just
got a lot of the general public's like
i think people like me because i give so
many people that
shouldn't be their hope you know like
you know like i give
every person like every white bat like
every skinny kid out there hope that
they can go and play sport whatever it
is like
definitely not a goat but i think i've
given a lot of hope to
sort of people that for me i look at
myself i'm like i shouldn't be out there
like there's not a chance i should be on
that field but
um just the way it's all panned out and
yeah it's just sort of fallen that way
so i think you know
just the the hope of the battlers really
you're very relatable a lot of people
can relate to you
yeah i'd say like you're pretty
relatable to the agenda though because
like obviously i'm a better looking
person than you but like we're pretty
we're pretty similar in stature like our
attributes are pretty similar
uh yeah we've had similar careers as
well to be fair like
if you think about it we're actually
you've got the curly hair and the big
following but other than that like we're
pretty
we're pretty similar pretty similar lads
yeah just don't have the amount of kids
as you make so uh
work in progress
but anyway banksy um that probably wraps
it up there we've been talking
through your journey for some time and
what a journey it's been
um some career so many highs a few lows
but
um it's all part of the game and i've
obviously
loved watching you go through the graves
i've loved playing against you
playing with have i played with you not
sure if i played with it no
actually just on that quickly i think
the first time was uh
southern regions trials i think we're in
the same team but i'll dig in on the
bench
and it was in the mud out the back of
saint pete
a horrific day they put us on the
backfield it was that
and i think he came off and gave me
probably 10 minutes like stops
and i think that was my first
interaction with you as a
as a person and ever since then i didn't
know you between then and
um then in the canes and uh yeah except
for the the time at nike so
you've grown in my book um from that
from the point of not giving me any game
time to nappy to living with you so
appreciate it it's been uh
cheers to have me on mate it's uh it's
been good stuff and it's uh
been less torturous than i thought oh
that's good to hear you are one of the
lads of the game so
we had to get you on at some point and
um it's been a pleasure chatting through
your journey so
cheers for that banksy hey cheers